peut-être un coup de tonnerre sur le
tour de france de directeur sportif de
l'équipe festina ainsi que le médecin
ont été placés en garde à vue ils sont
entendus par la police
c'est le retour des héros emmanuel petit
bixente lizarazu et fabien barthez sont
tous rentrés au pays et là encore il
n'était pas seul fabien barthez sera
avec nous dans ce journal
la situation reste très tendue ce soir
dans le midi de la france les pompiers
sont sur le qui vive hier soir ils ont
dû faire face à 150 départs de feu
et puis c'est ce qu'on appelle une
visite controversée le syrien hafez
el-assad arrive en france demain
illustration d'un revirement progressif
de la politique française au proche
orient et qui enfin des images de fait
celle de carcassonne de paris des
endroits où la fête du 14 juillet a été
particulièrement illumine madame
monsieur bonsoir la menace planait sur
le tour depuis son retour en france
chacun se demandait quand les
responsables de l'équipe festina serait
entendu par les policiers du srpj de
lille une perspective qui s'était encore
renforcé quand le soigneur de l'équipe
festina arrêté à la frontière belge avec
un grand nombre de produits dopants
avait affirmé qu agir à la demande de
ses dirigeants
ce soir c'est donc chose faite bruno
c'est le directeur sportif ainsi que le
médecin de l'équipe ont été emmenés par
les policiers dès l'arrivée de la 4e
étape pour être placé en garde à vue au
commissariat de cholet
l'anc est sur place d'olivier galzi et
de françois privat
comment réagissez-vous mission la scène
la police ne le laissera pas s'exprimer
abassourdi bruno roussel a tout juste le
temps de prendre un pull le directeur
sportif de l'équipe festina vient d'être
interpellé à quelques dizaines de mètres
à peine de la ligne d'arrivée
une opération discrète malgré la foule
menées par les enquêteurs
venu directement de lille comment
réagissez-vous mée-sur-seine l'attendiez
alors oui nous y voilà
mais bruno roussel s'attendaient à une
simple audition or il est placé en garde
à vue
une garde à vue qui pourrait durer
quatre jours deux minutes à peine après
avoir déposé bruno roussel au
commissariat de cholet
le srpj de lille repart en opération
cette fois ci c'est une perquisition à
l'hôtel de l'équipe festina dans un
camion ne saisissent une mallette
médical qu'ils iront ouvrir à
l'intérieur de l'hôtel à l'abri des
regards indiscrets
ce soir à cholet on ne parlait pas du
vainqueur de l'étape le tour de france
est sous le choc alors illégal si vous
êtes sur place bruno roussel le
directeur sportif de festina avait bien
réclamé lui même cette audition depuis
plusieurs jours mais il ne s'attendait
peut-être pas à être placé en garde à
vue
non effectivement il ne s'y attendait
pas en tout cas pas de cette manière là
comme on vous le disait tout à l'heure à
peine la ligne d'arrivée passée par le
peloton la voiture de bruno roussel
était juste derrière et bien quelques
mètres à peine de cette ligne un
gendarme lui a demandé de se dévier et
de tourner à gauche alors il l'a fait il
était un peu surpris et au bout en bout
et bien il y avait les enquêteurs l'un
d'entre eux lui a lu ses droits ils
étaient surpris il a demandé s'il
pouvait téléphoner à son avocat
évidemment l'enquêteur a répondu que oui
il a aussi répondu qu'il pourrait le
voir au bout de soixante treize heures
de garde à vue ce qui signifierait que
c'est une garde à vue stupéfiants est
donc une procédure qui pourrait durer
quatre jours encore
alors j'imagine olivier que c'est une
surprise de normes sur le tour oui ben
on
c'est une surprise évidemment les gens
des milliers de gens étaient venus pour
voir le peloton et nocibé ne s'imaginait
pas effectivement s'attendre à un
dénouement pareil et puis ce qu'il faut
dire aussi c'est que en ce moment même
le seul à se poursuit derrière moi bruno
roussel est toujours entendu et à
l'hôtel la perquisition elle se poursuit
comme vous allez le voir sur les images
qui viennent juste d'être tournée le
médecin de l'équipe de festina et rich
rieker tu as été emmenés dans le bus de
l'équipe pour être entendu par les
enquêteurs
alors évidemment on ne sait pas ce qu'il
s'est dit puisque comme vous le voyez le
bus a été refermée mais encore en ce
moment ils continuent à être entendu et
on ne sait toujours pas s'il repartira
libre ou s'il sera lui aussi placé en
garde à vue comme bruno roussel merci
olivier il faut préciser que le soigneur
de l'équipe lui est toujours inculpé et
écroué à la maison d'arrêt de loos les
lille
cette affaire de dopage ou en tout cas
de trafic de produits dopants empoisonne
le tour de france depuis le début
certains parlent quand d'autres
observent un silence gêné et prudent
florent gautreau et alain poirier
visage fermé long silence et sourires de
circonstance drôle d'ambiance pour un
tour de france
l' affaire festina a jeté un froid dans
le peloton car si les coéquipiers de vie
rentes sont en première ligne
tous les coureurs se sentent concernés
la première semaine du tour d'ordinaire
très joyeuse
ressemble un long chemin de croix oui
assez pâle fois ça a cassé quelque chose
dont le départ en irlande
ensuite la faire bon ben on est pas on
n'est pas dans un marché euphorique du
doigt les performances restent dans
l'ombre et la polémique éclate au grand
jour les coureurs ne supporte pas la
suspicion dont ils font l'objet et qu'on
entend l'expression tous dopés le monde
du vélo
un réflexe d'autodéfense c'était 400
inscrits parce que nous sommes en plus
qu'à sauter tout le monde
autre était content d'être africain à
17h30 jean marie leblanc apprend que
bruno roussel va être entendu par la
police
on en oublierait presque que le maillot
jaune a encore changé des pôles
la course passe au second plan c'est le
sort de l'équipe festina qui est en jeu
on a cherché à nous faire exclure les
coureurs ou à nous inciter à pousser
l'équipe festina en dehors du tour de
france il n'en a jamais été question
tu t'étais profondément injuste pour les
coureurs
il ne méritait pas ça pendant les
affaires le tour continue les coureurs
cours
les courageux s'échapper les sprinteurs
sprint mais le coeur n'y est plus
vraiment et déjà occulté par la coupe du
monde le tour de france fait maintenant
parler de lui dans la rubrique des faits
divers l'épreuve reine du cyclisme
mondial traverse la une de ces crises
les plus graves et les rumeurs de
retrait de l'équipe festina ne sont pas
là pour améliorer l'ambiance dans le
peloton et cette affaire avait pris
encore plus d'ampleur ce matin avec la
publication par le journal france soir
des propos d'un médecin suisse le
docteur gremion l'homme sait de quoi il
parle puisqu'il s'est occupé de coureur
cycliste
et il affirme tout simplement que les
cyclistes professionnels sont presque
tous dopés des accusations bien sûr
aussitôt contesté olivier caroff et
verrines et fichés
le p o ce produit dopant que
transportait le soigneur de festina il
suffit parfois d'une simple ordonnance
pour se le procurer
nous sommes ensuite si nous ne repartons
pas avec les doses de p o c'est que
cette pharmacie est en rupture de stock
en stock mais nous devons la commande
est donc pour demain matin pour la voir
son problème demain matin comme un matin
sans faute des substances de ce genre le
docteur gremion de lausanne s'en voit
demander de plus en plus souvent par des
cyclistes de plus en plus jeunes
aujourd'hui il accuse les coureurs
professionnels d'avoir donné le mauvais
exemple
selon lui il serait presque tous dopés
en remportant en nombre de coureurs
cyclistes qui prennent des produits
interdits qui me prennent actuellement
de manière contrôlée est ce qui fait qu
s'explique pourquoi on surprend le
contrôle même inopinés que les
maladroits ya déjà d'autres médecins
n'est pas d'accord il s'occupe entre
autres de richard virenque l'instar de
festina à qui il a prescrit une cure de
produits illicites pour lui les produits
saisis n'étaient pas destinées à doper
les cours allaient nord c'est tellement
invraisemblable de se balader avec des
quantités pareil que c'est ces points
séparent une quantité nécessaire à
l'emploi immédiat c'est un stock mais un
stock destiné à qui en france d'autres
médecins parlent d'un trafic au sein
même de la caravane du tout aidé à des
soigneurs qui qui gravitent dans
l'environnement du tour de france et qui
vendent des produits dopants qui vivent
de son manteau ou plus ou moins
ouvertement
non quand même et ils vont pas mettre
leurs étalages dans l'hôtel de la
direction du tour et de vendre les
produits
mais c'est connu par les patrons des
équipes c'est connu par les
organisateurs
s'ils ne savent pas ce qui se passe
c'est qu'effectivement il faut qu'ils
changent de lunettes avec l' affaire
festina le tabou du dopage commence à
être levés phénomène marginal ou fléau
généralisée c'est la justice qui
apportera peut être une réponse
et cette affaire de produits dopants a
été évoquée jusqu'au conseil des
ministres ce matin marie george buffet
pour la jeunesse et des sports a
réaffirmé son souhait que l'enquêté
aille jusqu'au bout tout en estimant
qu'il n'y avait aucune raison d'arrêter
le tour de france le projet de loi
antidopage déjà adopté par le sénat
devrait être présenté dès cet automne à
l'assemblée
enfin les sponsors de l'équipe festina
menace de cesser leurs financements si
les accusations de dopage se confirme
revenons maintenant aux bleus et à
l'équipe de france après les émotions de
ces trois derniers jours sur le terrain
tout d'abord ensuite sur les champs et à
l'elysée l'heure est venue pour les 22
héros d'aimé jacquet de prendre comme on
dit un repos bien mérité certains ont
choisi de rentrer chez eux et il est
difficile dans ces cas là de rester
discret voyons d'abord comment s'est
fait le retour de fabien barthez à leval
l'année dans sa ville natale dans
l'ariège christophe la rocca et gilbert
uzein
on le savait magie cieux le voici
équilibristes devant des milliers
d'admirateurs venus de toute l'ariège et
de bien au delà fabien lève le masque
il redevient l'enfant du pays celui qui
découvre ici le football à 7 ans tous
les matins devant la porte
barthez moi j'ai débuté au petit mais je
n'aurais jamais pensé le voir en équipe
de france et au niveau où il est arrivé
jamais je n'aurais cru le voir la jolie
je voudrais juste embrassé le trend de
sadio narcose c'est le fantasme de bien
des françaises
lui pourtant restent modestes
distribuant ses maillots s'excusant
presque de ne pas avoir réussi dans le
rugby comme son père al ahmar thèse ou
patrick estève
l'autre enfant du pays dans le rugby
j'adore énormément énormément le rugby
émotion aussi lorsque fabien retrouve
son vieil entraîneur le premier homme
qui l'a conduit à des sommets qu'il ne
réalise pas encore je rêvais même pas je
réalise même pas et je suis pas encore à
ce stade je suis très ému et content
fabien le modeste qui laisse la gloire
aux autres comme ce sosie qui depuis
dimanche a beaucoup beaucoup de succès
mais on voit que le baiser sur le crâne
et plus en plus répondu on retrouvera
bien sûr fabien barthez d'ici quelques
instants en attendant continuons de voir
comment se passe le retour au pays des
bleus avec maintenant emmanuel petit le
dernier à avoir marqué dans ce mondial
6000 personnes enthousiastes
l'attendaient à
saint-nicolas-d'aliermont en normandie
thierry kurt et et grégoire rosina 10
sont venus ils sont tous là pour le
retour du fils chéri
saint nicolas d'aliermont ses 4200
habitants sur la place devant l'hôtel de
ville ou moins 5000 personnes
un échange d'une grande sincérité
emmanuel petit a tenu tout de suite
après les folies parisienne à rendre
visite à ses parents en seine-maritime
fait citoyen d'honneur en mairie
mais vite rendu à son fan club
alors vous
m
celles qui le font
j'ai maintenant qu'elle y avait un
souvenir
non
son père ému jusqu'aux larmes se
souvient d'une prémonition emmanuel à
rêver il y a quelques années qu'ils
gagnaient une finale de coupe du monde
face au brésil 2 à 0 mais non non y'a
pas transformer son rêve parce qu'en
fait c'est réveiller trois tendances en
rêve parce qu'elle n'a pas vu la fin et
l'a prévu la part du rêve n'avait pas vu
qu'il marque un but en fait modeste
jusque dans ses rêves faire plaisir à
ceux qui ont cru en lui et un devoir
mais les sollicitations sont nombreuses
alors ils s'organisent
j'ai trois signatures différentes
j'ai la raisin plus rapide c'est la
musique que je me sens si les gens me
suivent la tête elle a du mal lisez mon
fils et de trucs mais ce n'était pas
suffisant pour gommer deux nuits
blanches enfin les vacances elles seront
courtes à peine quinze jours avant de
reprendre l'entraînement didier
deschamps et rentrait lui aussi mais
plus discrètement ainsi que bixente
lizarazu au pays basque
une fête est prévue demain soir hendaye
ronaldo s'est également mise au vert ces
cas de vire au brésil alors que toute la
presse s'interroge sur le malaise dont
il a été victime juste avant la finale
des convulsions qui ont nécessité un
examen complet à l'hôpital et qu'ils ont
visiblement beaucoup diminué sur le
terrain christelle bertrand ronaldo
n'est pas en pleine forme
on peut même dire qu'il a bien du mal à
descendre l'escalier depuis son retour
au brésil
les rumeurs les plus folles courent sur
son état de santé ronaldo aurait eu une
crise d'épilepsie ou de tétanie le jour
de la finale
une chose est sûre trois heures avant le
match il était à l'hôpital
arrivé tout à fait normalement marchant
normalement et dans un état normal
nous avons fait une série d'examens
complémentaires ici que sur le plan
clinique et examens complémentaires
majri ou autre chose et tous ces
résultats ont été communiqués au méthane
qui brésilienne et c'est en fonction de
ces résultats comme médecin de l'équipe
brésilienne a pris sa décision de faire
jouer ronaldo alors tout le monde
s'inquiète même le président de son club
c'est une énorme erreur de l'avoir
inclus dans l'équipe
quelques heures plus tôt il souffrait de
convulsions l'attitude de l'encadrement
a été stupide les conséquences de leurs
actes pouvaient avoir de graves
conséquences
ils ont oublié que ronaldo est un homme
pas seulement un joueur à la fin du
match mario zagallo a reconnu que le
problème de ronaldo a perturbé son
équipe
mais le sélectionneur brésilien est
accusé d'avoir subi des pressions du
principal sponsor pour faire jouer
ronaldo au brésil
les critiques fusent l'enfant chéri de
toute une nation va avoir bien du mal à
surmonter tout ça est le sponsor en
question à qui a assuré n'être jamais
intervenu dans cette histoire en marge
du mundial sachez qu'une autre voiture
folle a blessé dix personnes dans la
nuit de dimanche à lundi sous les champs
elysées son conducteur un avocat
britannique a été interpellé et mis en
examen
et puis à propos de l' enquête sur
l'agression dont est victime le gendarme
nivelles un hooligan allemand de 27 ans
qui était recherché s'est présenté
lui-même à la police deux autres et
hooligans arrêtés hier ont été mises en
examen et écrouées en allemagne dans la
région de marseille 500 pompiers restent
sur le qui vive hier il leur a fallu se
battre contre 150 départs d'incendié est
aujourd'hui le vent est resté fort
le reportage de caroline marie et michel
commun ont signalé l'un fumée suspecte
niveau de ces julien les martigues
le centre opérationnel de marseille
c'est ici que s'organise la lutte contre
les incendies les pompiers sont en
alerte rouge prêts à intervenir sur
plusieurs foyers en même temps hier dans
les nombreux départs de feux sur
l'ensemble du département
c'est un ensemble de moyens aériens
terrestres de surveillance d' alerte a
parfaitement fonctionné puisque tous les
départs de feux ont été cantonnés sur
des superficies que 120 réduite à la
plus grande qui était venu de ranchi
surveiller coordonnées anticipées c'est
le travail quotidien des pompiers mais
ils font un peu démuni face aux actes de
malveillance les pompiers quel qu'ils
soient marins sapeurs sont là pour
lutter contre l'adversité contre la vie
chère contre la difficulté contre les
catastrophes mais qu' ils ne peuvent pas
ils sont impuissants contre une volonté
humaine de nuire car il reste à
déterminer l'origine des 150 départs de
feu à marseille la nuit dernière les
fumigènes du 14 juillet l'imprudence
n'explique pas tout mardi soir un
pyromane a été interpellé en flagrant
délit dans l'est de la ville
c'est un mineur il a été remis à ses
parents aujourd'hui la mort de monsieur
mac do richard mcdonald le créateur des
fameux restaurant ou en tout cas de la
formule de restauration rapide est mort
la nuit dernière aux états unis
il avait 89 ans et sa marque au même
titre que coca cola est devenu en
quelque sorte l'emblème des états unis à
travers le monde
julienne son nom a fait le tour de la
planète pourtant richard mcdonald ne
pouvait imaginer un tel succès en 1948
lorsqu'il ouvre son premier restaurant
en californie avec son frère
hamburgers et frites une carte réduite
au minimum des produits faciles à
préparer vendus à des prix imbattables
le succès est immédiat leur fournisseur
de machines à milk shake ray kroc sans
la bonne affaire il achète aux frères mc
donald's le concept et le nom et c'est
lui qui dans les années 60 va développer
la chaîne de restaurants à travers tous
les états unis
la jeunesse américaines raffolent des
hamburgers à 1 franc
les ouvertures se multiplient 500
restaurants 1963 23000 aujourd'hui
répartis dans 111 pays et partout la
même formule partout les mêmes méthodes
de travail
enseigner ici à l'université du
hamburger au siège de la compagnie dans
la banlieue de chicago
chaque année des milliers de salariés
futurs directeurs de restaurants
viennent pour apprendre les recettes et
surtout l'esprit mac do venus du monde
entier ces étudiants sont choyés car
c'est d'abord à l'étranger en asie
notamment que mcdonald's se développe
l'an dernier plus de 2000 restaurant est
ouvert leurs portes
hors des frontières américaines ces
succès commercial les frères mcdonald's
n'auront guère profité eux qui pourtant
avait tout inventé
il y à 50 ans alors nous trouvons tout
de suite à lavelanet dans l'ariège où se
trouve maintenant fabien barthez fabien
barthez bonsoir vous allez bien ça se
passe bien ce retour au pays
on ne vous lâche pas la presse ni vos
fans
non c'est vrai qu'il ya pas mal pas mal
de monde j'ai d'ailleurs été très très
surpris je m'attendais pas à avoir à
voir l'accueil si chaleureux aussi je
sais pas il ya du monde de qui viennent
d'assez loin quand même beaucoup
vous n'avez pas pris conscience d'être
un héros un parmi parmi 22 23 et qui met
jacquet excusez moi je vous ai manhattan
vous n'avez pas tout à fait pris
conscience d'être un héros national
non pas du tout non non non non pas du
tout on a
je sais pas si même les 22 août à terry
encore c'est patronales et l'a donc ce
qu'on a vraiment vraiment besoin c'est
beaucoup beaucoup de calme et de repos
avant tout et vous pensez pouvoir la
voir ça avec tous les tous les gens qui
vous attend qu'ils veulent des
autographes partout qui vous qui vous
celui là rien je pense j'ai organisé
enfin j'ai organisé même monsieur le
maire lavelanet cette journée parce que
donc je voulais je voulais enchaîner
après ce qu'il se passe et comment ça
pour pouvoir bien me partir bien me
reposer dans un endroit assez tranquille
donc j'avais organisé c'est toujours là
exprès pour après vraiment un coupé
coupé de tout vous avez beaucoup de
vacances devant vous mais il me reste 13
jours de vacances et après ces trois
jours après on reprend valais as monaco
ont donc c'est vrai que c'est pas
beaucoup donc qu'est ce qui vous manque
le plus là maintenant que la coupe du
monde est terminée équation les petits
bisous de laurent blanc non ce qui me
manque beaucoup on a passé deux mois
ensemble donc comme je vous ai dit alors
c'est beaucoup beaucoup de repos et avec
du calme et retrouverait vraiment les
vrais amis on en a pas beaucoup
bon j'en ai quelques uns ici et c'est
retrouver les vrais amis et refaire
comme allende
comment vous avez vécu 7 7 jours mais
ces dernières journées à paris à
l'elysée avec tout le gotha parisien
politique qui qui se pressait autour de
vous mais c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
tellement ma tasse de thé ce genre de
truc donc j'étais assez fatigué j'ai
pareil donc j'ai vu j'ai vu que j'ai
vécu ça comme chez pas comme la plupart
des joueurs je pense donc comme une
contrainte c'était une bonne journée
c'est une belle journée sais pas c'était
pas pénible à vivre ce n'est pas une
contrainte quand même non c'est pas une
contrainte parce que le bon c'est
vraiment un honneur d'être reçu par le
président la république donc à l'elysée
c'est pas de contrainte ça fait ça fait
partie du boulot il faut faire avec donc
comme cet après midi il fallait que je
passe ici
voilà quoi donc c'est le boulot en
quelque sorte
alors on vous a entendu presque vous
justifiez sur le rugby dans ce pays de
rugby
comment se fait-il que vous n'ayez pas
choisi le rugby au départ à j'ai pas
choisi le rugby parce que tout ça s'est
fait naturellement quoi ça s'est fait
tout seul j'ai joué bien jusqu'à l'âge
de 15 ans mais bon après j'ai bifurqué
sur le football donc je suis assez là
dessus et un joli la première sélection
mois après et il avoue la petite
histoire quand vous allez atterrir enfin
parce que j'imagine qu'un jour vous
allez atterrir après tous ces événements
et toute cette émotion quelles sont les
images que vous allez le garder de la
coupe du monde
les images que je vais garder ça se
coupe du monde il y en a il y en a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup c'est ça me
paraît en même temps ça me paraît loin
cette coupe du monde mais bon j'ai
l'image de tous ses matches de ces
actions tous ces moments après les
matches
c'est des images qui reviennent sans
cesse et c'est s'est vécue au jour le
jour tous les jours tous les jours donc
assurément un sur me remémore tous quoi
bon en tout cas pas une image en
particulier et c'est une ambiance un
collectif et est ce que vous avez vécu
pendant pendant ce séjour avec tous ses
joueurs
excusez moi je vous le disais c'est une
ambiance et un un collectif de vie avec
tous ses joueurs pendant tout séjour
vous de montants les plus faibles bien
en tout cas je vous remercie beaucoup au
nom de la relève sur france 2 nous avoir
consacré un tabac je vous remercie nous
avoir consacré encore un petit peu de
temps alors qu'on vous sollicite
beaucoup nous et d'autres depuis cette
cette merveilleuse victoire en finale de
la coupe du monde merci fabien barthez
rockets le président syrien hafez
el-assad commence demain en france une
visite controversée cela fait 22 ans qui
n'était pas venue à paris il sort
d'ailleurs très peu de son pays qu'il
gouverne d'une main de fer est où le
problème de sa succession se pose depuis
la mort accidentelle de son fils aîné
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux en
syrie philippe rochot et jacques gerin
le lissier de lattaquié où hafez el
assad a fait ses études au temps du
mandat français avant d'entrer dans
l'armée
sa statue rappelle que la clé du pouvoir
en syrie se trouve ici dans cette
communauté alaouite minoritaire à
laquelle il appartient mais qui a donné
ses dirigeants au pays
son image est partout mais ça m'a de
faire dans le conflit du proche-orient
impose encore le respect avant tout
c'est le premier président dans les pays
arabes qui a fait qu'ils avaient et une
stratégie très claire contre israël a
fait el-assad ministre de la défense
pendant la défaite arabe de 67 s'est
emparé du pouvoir trois ans plus tard
dans un pays qui détenait le record des
coups d'état et depuis il a déjoué tous
les complots comme celui des frères
musulmans
vingt mille morts à rama dans la
répression menée par les brigades de son
frère rifaat nostalgique de la grande
syrie assad impose sa loi au liban avec
30000 de ses soldats mais la succession
d'assad sera difficile et l'héritage
lourd à porter dans son fief de care
dahra on pleure encore ce fils prodigue
bassel el assad mort il ya quatre ans
dans un accident de voiture
c'est lui qui devait prendre la
succession d'assad la mort l'a fauché à
32 ans
nous avons aménagé le tombeau de bassel
pour trois raisons la cause de la
pression des gens recevront les
bienfaits que basse elle a prodigué à la
jeunesse et par suite de l'afflux des
visiteurs qui viennent lui rendre aux
marches marbre devant le mausolée qui
lui sera dédiée on voir hafez al assad
regardez son fils cavalier émérite aimé
de la jeunesse du pays monte au ciel
la syrie ne se remet pas de la mort du
fils en a mis là il a aidé les sportifs
ont vraiment emblème
c'était un homme de ruth retrouve
partout peut être dans un café avec les
laisons dans les rues avec dans les
matchs de football
c'est pour ça que vous avez été aussi
attristé par sa mort est tellement
triste et par sa maman tellement parce
que c'était ce prix vous êtes choqués
parce que un accident voiture n'est plus
là
le régime entretient le culte du fils
commune entretient le culte du père il
veut prouver aussi rien que le pouvoir
ne peut venir que de la famille assad
et ça marche sur son balcon ce jeune a
même construit une statue de bassel en
hommage à son oeuvre
c'est par fidélité à l'âme de ce martyr
que j'ai fait c'est la moindre des
choses pour garder le souvenir de basse
elle charrie nous a donné l'espoir mais
basse elle n'est plus et comme
l'illustrent cette peinture naïve les
rênes du pouvoir devront passer à son
frère de 31 ans bachar trop jeune pas
encore formée alors que le temps presse
pour préparer la succession d'hafez
el-assad
cette visite je vous le disais et
controversée le président syrien a été
longtemps diabolisés par la france est
considérée encore par les états unis ou
l'angleterre comme le responsable d'un
état terroriste
mais depuis quelques années depuis la
visite de jacques chirac en syrie en 96
la france à réorienter sa politique au
moyen-orient et repris le chemin de
damas les explications de philippe
rochon ce bain de foule de jacques
chirac et d'hafez el-assad à damas à
marquer les retrouvailles franco
syrienne la syrie doit encore dans la
france l'héritière de la politique du
général de gaulle qui condamne à israël
pour avoir déclenché la guerre de 67
françois mitterrand avait recentré cette
politique en se rapprochant de jérusalem
jacques chirac revient sur le chemin de
damas aujourd'hui la syrie veut effacer
sa réputation d'état terroriste ou des
carlos d abou nidal des armées jibril
avait pignon sur rue à damas dans les
années 80 la france de son côté a tourné
la page de l'assassinât de notre
ambassadeur au liban louis delamare en
81 alors que les syriens a été soupçonné
la présence de l'armée syrienne au liban
acceptée par la france permet à la syrie
de tenir un nouveau front face à israël
le contrôle que la syrie exerce sur les
350 mille réfugiés palestiniens de syrie
et les quatre cent mille réfugiés
palestiniens du liban lui donne une
carte maîtresse dans le conflit enfin sa
volonté de récupérer la partie du golan
occupé par israël depuis la guerre de 67
fait de la syrie un partenaire
incontournable mais le processus de paix
est bloqué et damas compte sur paris
pour aider à le relancer
les deux présidents veux voir comment la
france et la syrie
les européens et les arabes including y
compris des américains aux peuvent faire
revivre pourrait sauver ce processus de
pêche pétrole avant qu'il ne soit trop
tard et states
en se tournant vers paris la syrie veut
montrer que les états unis trop lié à
israël ne saurait détenir le monopole
des négociations de paix et que la
france peut de nouveau jouer un rôle
capital
au proche orient la russie s'apprête à
enterrer les restes de nicolas 2 le
dernier de s'armer beaucoup en russie à
commencer par l'église orthodoxe doute
que les ossements exhumés dans les
environs d'ekaterinbourg soient bien
ceux de la famille impériale de cette
cérémonie qui devrait être celle de la
réconciliation nationale risque de
rouvrir certaines plaies dans le pays 80
ans après l'exécution du dernier tsar
par les communistes
les deux français enlevés au large de la
somalie il ya un mois et demi sont
toujours dans les mains de leurs
ravisseurs leur famille ont fait savoir
qu'elles étaient prêtes à payer une
partie de la rançon d'environ 450 mille
francs mais au quai d'orsay en précise
que la politique de la france est de ne
jamais céder au chantage et puis une
baisse de la tva est bien à l'étude dans
l'équipe gouvernementale une baisse qui
concernerait certains produits françois
hollande deux premiers secrétaires du ps
demandé ce matin sur europe 1 que les
secteurs de l'énergie et de la
restauration soit les premiers visés
et puis à propos de dépenses de
l'assurance-maladie la hausse au mois de
mai de plus de 0 4% ce qui fait une
progression de 6% pour les cinq premiers
mois de l'année un niveau très élevé
hier soir toute la france c'était en
fait pour le 14 juillet à carcassonne la
ville qui est classé au patrimoine
mondial depuis maintenant sept mois
fêter les 100 ans de son embrasement
karine comazzi et françoise mazou en
sont encore tout émerveillé
la nuit tombe doucement sur les berges
de l'aude où campent depuis des heures
touristes et habitués
j'en ai vu deux jolies mais il paraît
qu'aujourd'hui il va être magnifique
la foule est immense et le silence
presque religieux connaissent en tant
que s'embrase les remparts médiévaux de
la cité l'engouement n'a pas pris une
ride
seuls les techniques ont évolué au
milieu de kilomètres de files
une quinzaine d'articles c'est
s'activent malgré le très sophistiqué
système pierrot digital qui déclenche
les fusées au dixième de seconde
ça reste très artisanal de temps en
temps parce qu'il faut s'adapter au
terrain il ya des dépositions de deux
produits qu'on ne peut pas adopter ou
des escaliers dans les
on avait pas prévu sur les plans qu'il
faut qu'il faut décaler le produit il
faut fixer le produit en cours
souvent il ya 600 mètres de façade de
feu sur deux étages au total en une
soirée 50km de slalom entre les fusées
12 tonnes de matière inerte 600 bombe
rien que pour le bouquet final le tout
savamment disposées sur des remparts
fraîchement classée au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco
de quoi faire frémir la caisse des
bâtiments historiques
mais l'affairé est à ce prix
et à paris le feu d'artifice sur le
champ de mars a tenu toutes ses
promesses en revanche le spectacle de
jean michel jarre qui la précédait n'a
pas plu à tout le monde
il faut dire que le compositeur avait
choisi de l'accompagner par de la
musique techno sophie mais elle est
josselin permission un feu d'artifice
pour en bloc c'était la musique le 14
juillet encore la coupe du monde de foot
on s'en lasse toujours pas
la soirée avait bien démarré à 19 heures
la foule se massait déjà au champ de
mars pour ne pas en manquer une miette
une occasion supplémentaire de se
rassembler en ces jours de patriotisme
exalté on aurait tort de ne pas en
profiter
cinq cent mille personnes ont répondu à
l'appel mais pour entendre les premières
vibrations de jean michel jarre il
fallut attendre jusqu'à 22h30 la foule
qui piétine et l'artiste qui se fait
attendre une demi-heure plus tard c'est
le raz-de-marée
direction la sortie
3 pensez vous et pourtant le spectacle
donné autant à voir qu'à entendre son
synthétique et images psychédéliques
ça n'est certes pas du goût de tout le
monde mais comment faire l'unanimité
prenons maintenant sur le tour de france
sur son aspect sportif avec la 4e étape
entre plouay cholet la plus longue étape
cette année qui a été remporté par un
néerlandais le maillot jaune lui a une
nouvelle fois changer des pôles françois
brabant pour une étape comme celle là
faire la circulation
c'est pas bien compliqué on fais juste
attention rond-point et après c'est tout
droit
deux cent cinquante deux kilomètres à
parcourir jusqu'au cholet c'est la plus
longue étape de ce tour 98 une route
interminable qui s'étire sur les terres
de bretagne en voiture ça pourrait
devenir fastidieux heureusement en vélo
c'est plus rigolo et vu du ciel c'est
beau et quand on descend du ciel on
tombe sur deux échappés deux échappés
français monsieur daniel nazon et jacky
duran duran qui à un moment et même
virtuel maillot jaune mais voilà la
route est longue et le peloton finit par
revenir une fois les deux échappés
avaler on se prépare un sprint massif
mais le tour de france est plein de
mauvais génie qui s'amusent à tous
contrarie et afin de kilomètres de
l'arrivée
c'est la chute
dans cette chute se trouve mario
cipollini l'italien le meilleur
sprinteur du peloton et l'australien
stuart o'grady qui vient de remporter
deux sprints de bonification les deux
hommes repartent mais c'est un troisième
le néerlandais blade events qui
l'emportent pour tripoli ni c'est une
journée pour rien pour o'grady c'est une
journée qui finit bien
il devient le deuxième australien de
l'histoire a endossé le maillot jaune
seize ans après phil anderson et a remis
hier soir c'est le record du 400 m qui a
été très nettement battus le marocain el
guerrouj a parcouru la distance en 3
minutes et 26 secondes exactement
effaçant du même coup la performance de
son grand rival qui lui est algérien
passé la coupe du monde et le 14 juillet
c'est pour beaucoup leur du vrai départ
en vacances alors sachez que vous êtes
très attendu surtout sur les plages
elles ne représentent que 4% du
territoire national mais l'été bien
exploitées elles peuvent rapporter
beaucoup d'argent
le reportage sur l'une des plus célèbres
d'entre elles celle de pampelonne près
de saint tropez jean jacques dufour et
blaise premier vu d'ici la grande plage
de pampelonne sait jamais du sable
oui mais avec la mer à côté ce sable
c'est de l'or en barre
d'ailleurs le matin les plagistes
ressemblent un peu à des heures fire qui
dit chaleur fait pitié pour vendre faut
que ça brille
le client y va arriver là j'avais il va
y avoir trois mégots a compté va y avoir
un mégot j'exagère impôts donc au boulot
la saison écourtée la concurrence
impitoyable
sur ces 27 hectares de paillettes dorées
qui attire plus de trente mille
personnes chaque été il y a quand même
26 établissements privés les affaires
commerciales dans le chiffre d'affaires
global est d'environ 200 millions de
francs par saison
c'était un sable qui rapportent de
l'ordre oui c'est difficile la tamise et
ses plages dites privées ne le sont pas
vraiment puisque elles appartiennent à
l'état et que les communes qui les
gèrent n'accorde que des concessions
limitées dans le temps et le temps c'est
de l'argent tenait quand paul bande des
castels s'est établi à pampelonne en 60
de son petit bout de paradis coûté
seulement 500 francs aujourd'hui ça vaut
combien de concessions une concession ça
vaut 200 mille francs
c'est un nom normalement normalement
c'est un an renouvelable chaque année
les plages ainsi concédé rapporte
environ 5 millions de francs la commune
de ramatuelle et génère 500 emplois
directs des emplois des sous je vous
l'avais bien dit le sable est une valeur
sûre en tout cas c'est sûrement ce que
pense le groupe financier qui vient de
racheter deux concessions à quelques
centaines de mètres de celle de monsieur
paul des investisseurs qui n'ont pas
lésiné sur les moyens une plage
commercial ça doit être domptées
apprivoiser des ensauvagé vous avez
combien d'employés 38 personnes savaient
combien vous avez le matelas ici peu
près 180 par plage ce qui nous fait
environ 350 matelas en gros et nous
avons des réserves
des réserves certains en maîtres les
plages privées distille pour draguer
c'est pas le pied sur la pluie l'a privé
c'est bien pour dormir et la privée donc
pour dormir la plage publique provoque à
pampelonne les perdants des bords de mer
peuvent être aux anges il ya 22 hectares
de plage publique mais bien évidemment
c'est pas là que jérôme gagne sa vie
pour lui une plage sans matelas c'est
comme une journée sans pain la presse
m'a d'abord parce qu'elle est ma place
auprès des masses un peu plus dur donc
plus épais à propos de pain giraud bonne
pâte parle de tout sauf d'argent ici le
sujet est tabou que le problème de
l'argent avec les français on sait bien
c'est toujours délicat puisque dès
l'instant où on dit qu'on gagne de
l'argent on est suspect de gagner trop
d'argent
alors c'est pour ça que d'une façon
générale les gens n'aiment pas trop
enfin les commerçants ne veut pas dire
combien il gagne c'est ça le problème
oui mais comme nous sommes plus tenaces
disons danse voilà le chiffre d'affaires
de nos plages moyenne est d'environ 3
millions comme quoi finir sur le sable
c'est toujours mieux que sur la paille
et pas très loin de là à nice c'est le
50e anniversaire du festival de jazz
pour l'occasion les organisateurs ont
fait appel à un nouveau directeur
artistique michel leeb et yasmina farber
est libre a signé les places assises
sont parfois originales dans ce jardin
d'oliviers le jazz se vit tranquille en
famille une ambiance de kermesse avec un
passage incontournable au stand de la
soca sept spécialités niçoises à base de
farine de pois chiches devenue
légendaire moi quand je vois des gars
qui paie quand même cette année quoi la
soirée pour écouter comme il ya deux
années
ray charles mais qu'ils se mettent à la
queue projeté du crâne ne sont que je me
demande pourquoi les gens font etienne
d'un podium à l'autre en famille avec
les enfants est quelque chose de très
familial et très festif évidemment sur
cette période de l'année où on vient de
gagner la coupe du monde et où le ciel
est bleu avec la note bleue jazz yvon
blackburn va être plus heureux
la note bleue soirée funky avec botzi
collins le bâti sa quelques décennies
d'expérience derrière lui il a joué
aussi bien avec james blake avec lenny
kravitz beauty aime les étoiles c'est
moins sa vie pays-bas ce être sur scène
en plein air se fait planer
est ce en plein air vous avez de l'airf
et des arbres partout c'est une super
sensation
bonjour
bonnes vibrations sur les oliviers
l'ambiance d'un mini woodstock un jardin
en l'excentricité funk et le gel des
puristes 8 en parfaite harmonie
et puisque nous ne sommes pas loin du
rocher cette nouvelle importante sur
votre carnet rose stéphanie monaco a
donné naissance un troisième enfant une
petite fille prénommée camille marie
kelly kelly comme grâce que ce journal
est terminée je vous remercie de l'avoir
suivi je vous rappelle les principaux
titres c'est peut-être un coup de
tonnerre qui s'abat sur le tour de
france que directeur sportif de l'équipe
festina ainsi que le médecin avait été
placé en garde à vue ils seront entendus
ils sont entendus par la police c'est le
retour des héros emmanuel petit bixente
lizarazu fabien barthez sont tous
rentrés au prix là encore il n'était
pour seule la foule les attendait c'est
ce qu'on appelle une visite controversée
le sait rien fais el-assad arrive en
france demain illustration d'un
revirement progressive de la politique
française au proche orient dans un
instant la météo demain à 7h50 dans les
4 vérités manuel vanille recevra
jean-louis foulquier le directeur des
francofolies
je raconte à moi le plaisir de vous
retrouver demain soir à 20h et je vous
souhaite une bonne soirée sur france 2
non